Microsoft just released Windows 10 with
one kind of cool hidden feature for us
gamers you can stream your Xbox to your
PC now that's right you fire up the Xbox
app on your Windows 10 computer you may
serese streaming is enabled in the
System Preferences on your Xbox and then
you connect them to the same network and
you can connect them and then stream
yeah so we were wondering how well this
works like does it work can you do 60fps
and can you do multiplayer games voice
Chef is there like weird crazy latency
yeah any issues on Wi-Fi no no so we
tested all of that and guess what it
pretty much all works yeah we even got
60 frames per second in porta and AW
multiplayer with really no latency like
we were getting kills on a multiplayer
match which is pretty cool you've used a
lot of streaming systems how did this
one hold up from all the streaming
systems ah jeez this was like the least
noticeable latency which is like done
number one important issue with all the
streaming stuff no matter how good it
looks
it's the latency that always like kind
of ruins a system that's yeah that was
my impression of the Nvidia shield
PlayStation TV PlayStation now all that
stuff was like unplayable because it
would have even just a little bit of
latency it starts in full-screen mode
when you hit the stream button and we
are actually having tons of problems
with it in full-screen mode we had to
kind of like minimize back down and then
scale it as we wanted to but and then it
worked in windowed mode but yet for some
reason it just won't work in full-screen
yes I mean the streaming technology
seems to work but there's some like that
uh there's some problems with the system
as it stands which you know those could
be updated but voice chat works any mic
plugged in your PC as the record input
worked over a party chat on Xbox cool
seems worth mentioning that there's
three quality settings none of them were
like incredibly good-looking or
incredibly bad looking but when you go
to low you seem to drop yep yeah yeah it
seems jump to frame rate we could only
stream low over Wi-Fi for this part like
the only way I could see this kind of
thing being cool is let's say I could
scream my PC to my xbox dude now you're
talking yeah let me play Kerbal space
program on my TV with the Gordon Mouse
yeah without any additional purchases
because already have an Xbox already
have all the stuff on PC yeah I mean
Microsoft makes Windows 10 and the ex
there's no reason to let valve come in
and swoop this like cool idea and
Windows 10 is coming to the Xbox soon in
November I believe this fall I can see
it happening with just Windows 10 apps
like stuff you buy in the Xbox app in
Windows 10 streams the other way that I
could see happening that lien I said
like eliminate the need for a steam box
Valve's coming out with the $50 Dongo
called the steam link pretty much the
same thing but they were correct
direction but hey it works going this
way and it works and these are all the
questions you never had about it and we
tried to answer them how about that if
you got any questions you just make sure
to put it in the comments
you